So here's what I want to build and deploy as a Databricks app.
So what we have here is a UI design for Monday morning reports,
for CPG retail and sites for executives.
So we want to replicate practically everything that you see in the screen here,
total sales, comps, store sales, etc, etc.
This Ask Genie button should trigger off a request to Genie,
but Genie, I'll give you the specifics around the Genie MCP and whatnot.
But the idea here is that it is going to give you an executive brief and we can
generate the brief here by clicking this button and it should show you very
quickly what that looks like, you know, in generally, like what does it actually
mean, right? And then we also have these monthly to sales trends, sales by
category, the KPIs for individual categories, the top movers, the end-up
performers, you know, the new items, average basket size, conversion rate,
private label, fill rate, etc, and inventory health by store.
So we have this thing here going on.
And then we also have a small tab here that shows you the breakdown by individual
product. For every product we have, we have, you know, this sort of like this,
bubble chart with the map and, you know, individual locations, you know, being
shown out here for that, for that category, subcategories, queued or drill
down. And then we also have some executive briefs here.
If we need to add that later on, we can do that.
We also have, you know, Monday morning, I asked Genie here, which is basically all
the questions, all the things here are going to culminate into a question that
you can ask here in the chat for the Monday morning.
What I want to do is specifically want to build out this exact same capability
directly on Databricks and deploy that into Databricks.
We need to figure out the required requirements for this.
So what I mean when I say that is that we can make up the data, we can do
practically, you know, generate synthetic data for all these things and then go
from there. So I would like to see how the kind of PRD that you can write
against this information, right?